[Music]
well we certainly had so much fun
sharing with you yesterday about the
awesome dating app for dog lovers called
digg and today it's all about the cat
lovers out there who don't want to be
left behind
sisters lee d'angelo and casey isaacson
launched tabby
the cat person's dating app last august
on international cat day
they say it's all about helping people
find love during these times when it's
hard to get out and about and date
deangelo says generally straight men get
a bad rap if they are a cat lover and
she says this is unfounded
over the summer a new study came out
that said
that men perform worse on
general dating apps when they have a cat
in their photo
and women are more likely to swipe left
because of the stigma around
cats and when you meet a cat
guy and you're to describe them you'll
realize that they are
more compassionate more responsible
more caring and who doesn't want that in
a guy that you're looking for
there you go you can get on the tabby
app and tabbydates.com website for free
and be social with folks you just need
to upgrade to receive any direct
messages
and here's something else to make you
feel good a portion of proceeds from
tabby benefits cat rescue groups
and cats featured on the tabby dates
accounts and in marketing campaigns they
are all available
for adoption